Hey, so today, welcome to this
talk at Google with just late.
So I'm Dan Carey and joining me as Jess.
Hi.
She is a partner at sequoia capital.
Previously she was at Google as a product
manager and then Pauline bear Polyvore
which you joined as a product manager.
You were then VP of product honorary
cofounder and ultimately Ceo, uh,
led the company through the acquisition
with Yahoo in 2015. You were fortunate.
It's 40 under 40 list clamorous top
3,535 women in tech and a whole bunch of
other things. So welcome. Thanks
for, uh, thanks for coming.
Thanks for having me. So,
uh, so what's it like to
be back at Google? Oh,
totally.
Yeah, it's trippy. It's very surreal.
I used to sit in this building
and like 2000 and a 2005,
I think when it first opened. Um, yeah,
it's just, it's kind of cool to be back.
I learned a lot of things, uh,
on this campus. I was an APM, uh,
and I worked on frugal,
which was product search back in the day.
And then I asked for after shorts did
there I stayed at, I moved to Google maps,
but this was when Google maps was a
desktop product and we did not have
smartphones. So, um, it's
a pretty long time ago.
So you joining Polyvore right from Google.
Right.
And it was kind of a weird journey,
right?
Like it wasn't normal circumstances for
leaving Google and joining a company.
Yeah. Yeah. I would say it was a
little bit of an unusual path. Um,
so I remember I was sitting
at Google in my, uh,
in my office with another Google
maps pm and he was like, hey,
you should check out this site called
Polyvore that my friend is working on.
And I was like, okay. I checked it out and
I was like, oh my God, this is amazing.
Um,
what Polyvore does is it lets you mix
and match and create outfits out of real
products and you can create those
outfits and share them with your friends.
It's kind of like a fashion magazine
created by community of women all over the
world, but everything is
shockable. Um, so I fell in love.
I started using it two or three hours a
night and just couldn't get it out of my
brain. And then, uh, because
that was a pm I wrote,
I had a lot of complaints
about the product,
so I wrote them all down and I sent
an email to the cofounder and I,
one of the founders and I was
like, Hey, I love this product.
I think there's going to be huge, but
can you fix this, this, this, this, this,
and here are some suggestions
for how to fix them. Um,
and then he wrote back and said,
hey, these are all great suggestions.
Why don't you just come work here yourself
and fix, fix all this stuff yourself.
Um, and so that's what ended up
happening and that's how I ended up at,
at Polyvore.
So you filed a bug report
and got them assigned to you?
Yeah,
I do.
It's Polyvore is fantastic and awful.
My, my wife used to work at Polyvore, uh,
enjoying Polyvore for the same reason,
uh,
because she needed to pay for all
this stuff she was buying on Polyvore.
So it's a very good site.
So what was it about [inaudible] that
caught your interest when you're using it?
What clicked?
What made you so passionate about it?
So, uh, before getting into computer
science and Google and all that,
my original goal in life was
to be a comic book artist.
And because I love to draw a that just
up not working out because my parents
won't let me go to art school because
they're Asian and they thought it wasn't
like a legitimate career. Um, but
what drew me into Polyvore was, um,
the ability to self express.
I mean it's, it's, uh,
it was a creative tool ultimately,
and it was kind of at the intersection
of art and fashion and technology.
So I thought,
wow.
How often does something like that happen
where you pulls together a lot of your
passions? Uh, it's something that's
at the very earliest stage. Uh,
so if I went there,
even though there's not a lot there,
I would get the
opportunity to learn a ton,
which is actually reminded
me of the APM program. Um,
I got into the APM program thinking
like, okay, I don't know how to do,
I don't even know what a pm is,
but at least if I come here to
Google I'll grow and I'll learn.
Um, and you know, maybe maybe
it'll work, maybe it won't.
But at least I would
challenge myself and grow.
And that's exactly how I felt about
polygraphs. Like there's nothing here. Uh,
maybe I can volunteer and step up
and do some of those things and I'll,
I'll grow a lot.
And that's what ended up happening.
I actually kept volunteering to do
various different things at the company.
You know,
I was like,
Oh let me write the blogs since we
don't have a marketing person or let me
answer the phone when the advertisers
call, cause we don't have a sales team.
And then what ended up happening
is I would try that job,
learn just enough to be
a little bit dangerous,
like just enough and then figure out
it was a very good at it and then hire
someone else to do it.
But having done it myself,
I was a little bit better at finding
the right person to hire. And then, uh,
that person would inevitably
end up reporting to me
because I was the only sort
of business person at the time. And then
we just kept growing and eventually a,
all the departments were reporting into
me except for engineering and my title
was still VP of product.
And uh,
at that point we decided to make
the switch where I became CEO.
So very unusual path to sort of running
a company. But that, that, that was my,
yeah,
that's really interesting.
And in that time,
was there anything that you
came across it were like,
no way could never do this huge mistake.
Way Too dangerous at this?
Yeah. That was like everyday, I mean,
start ups are incredibly hard, right?
It's um, every day is a new
obstacle and I definitely felt like,
especially since I was growing quickly
and the company was growing every time I
felt like, okay, I've got it now.
I figured out how to do my job.
I think I might've figured it out.
Finally,
that feeling would like inevitably only
lasts for a brief moment because then
the company would get bigger and then
everything would change all over again.
You people,
you know,
the process that was the perfect for
communicating with 20 people broke at 50
people.
And then as we got that right,
it broke again at 75 and then
at 125 and then, you know,
it's just things when you're growing,
things just keep changing.
You just kind of have to get used
to the feeling of constantly, um,
not knowing what you're doing or not,
not knowing how to do something,
which is essentially the same thing as
learning. Yeah. I'm CICI kind of see,
I've always felt like you should seek
out that feeling and you should try to
find that really nauseous, horrible
feeling of I don't know what I'm doing.
Cause that's how, you know,
you're getting career growth.
And then was there anything ball,
you were a kind of the CEO of Polyvore
that kept you up at night. I mean,
what was your biggest worry about it?
Oh yeah.
Yeah. So specifically, um, I mean
there were so many things, uh,
you know, product market
fit, you know, did,
where we was our product serving
the users while we were very,
very community driven and
then figuring out like,
is the market that we're in big enough?
Do we have to evolve the product? Uh,
lots of hiring, lots of
the, especially later,
all the issues became very much
related to like people. Um,
so did I have the right VP of sales that
I have the right VP of engineering or
these people clicking?
I mean there were so many moments at
number strangely they all felt very
existential cause I think when you're the,
when you're running the company,
even your identity becomes intertwined
with the company's identity and every
bump in the road feels
very, very personal. Um,
which is part of what makes
a startups so hard. Yeah.
So I was kind of stalking you on your
sequoia page before this and you talk
about grit a little bit.
You talked about being able to create
delight and overcome obstacles. Um,
just kind of sticking with it.
I'm sure everything wasn't always like
on the up and up and it's a startup.
So there's tons of times where
you feel like you're dying. Yeah.
So any advice for people in
terms of developing grit?
Is it something that's an eight and you
just kind of have to express it or is it
something that you prefer?
Yeah, I definitely think, you
know, some people start out,
there's this concept of distance travel.
Like when you're looking at say an
interview candidate and you look at their
resume. I think if you look
at the distance traveled,
like where did they come from
and how far have they gone?
That's actually a good metric.
That's how I really think about grit.
Like if you started at an easier place
in life, um, like more privileged,
maybe your distance,
you know that your distance traveled might
actually be less than someone who had
none of the, the privilege.
So I think sometimes your,
your upbringing and where you came from,
that original distance travel to get to
where you are actually increases your
grid sort of naturally like could
be your family circumstances,
could be your socioeconomic classes.
But on top of that,
I think grit is something you
actually develop over time.
And the way you do that is you push
yourself to travel further. Um,
you get used to just forcing
yourself to do things that are hard,
that feel bad, that that nauseous feeling
of learning that I was talking about.
Um, and that's actually what increases
your grit because grid is really,
it's really pain tolerance.
So if you can put yourself into those
painful situations and the challenges
rather than kind of taking the
easy route or coasting, um, that's,
I think how you develop grit.
And I think grit is one of the most
important ingredients in startup founders
because it's just so hard. You don't
control so many of your circumstances.
You don't control what
happens with the market.
You can't control the fundraising climate.
You can't control what all the people
on your team, you know, decide to do,
or if there's a competitor that comes
along. So you really have to have grit.
You have to practice at getting it,
getting stronger and stronger to
put up with all the ups and downs.
So is that something you look for now
that you're on the other side of that
funding table now that you're at sequoia?
Yeah, absolutely. Um, you know,
I think a combination of Grit and passion,
right?
Like to get through the pain of just
the basics of starting a company. Um,
you either have to really care about the
problem and be mission oriented or you
have to have that natural grip,
but there's has to be
something driving you right.
Because on average it takes I think eight
or nine years to build a company from
ground zero to a successful outcome, like
an exit or large Mna. And so, you know,
to imagining that amount of time,
like it has to be something you probably
care about. One of the other great to,
to power through all the problems.
Yeah.
One of the other things that you mentioned
on your sequoia profiling and a few
other interviews that I've seen with you,
cause you talk about focusing on one thing
and doing it really, really well. Yeah.
That was one of the core values
that Polyvore yeah. Do one thing.
So how has that one thing kind of change?
I'm sure being a want to be comic
book artist being a PM at Google,
being at Polyvore and all those
different roles, it's changed a lot.
How do you kind of pick that one thing?
Yeah. You know, I,
I think when I was a a pm one of my
strengths with was I was actually empathy
was being able to think, you know, what
does the user want in this situation?
Like as they're printing out their driving
directions before Google back we used
to print driving directions
cause remember this is a desktop.
What are they thinking, what do they want?
And that empathy helps guide a lot of,
you know, product decisions.
Right. But then as you become,
you know, then I became,
you know,
uh,
I transitioned and at Polyvore I
started answering the phones for,
for sales calls. Then the
empathy was applied to, you know,
what does the advertiser won?
And like trying to research and understand
enough about the advertising industry
to imagine, okay, it's not
just this is an advertiser.
The person that I'm talking
to is an account manager.
At a large agency who was trying to
advance their career and wants to do good
for this client.
The client probably thinks this way and
be able to take all of that and figure
out what the right ad product was.
Then as the company got large and I
started managing people, it was, you know,
what am I,
what does my team care about?
Like where is this person in their career?
How do they feel about the current
state of the company, their team,
their career goals? And now that I'm on
the investor side, again that applies to,
you know,
try and understand the founder and the
trying to understand the market that
they're in, the users that they're
serving, what do they care about? Right.
So I would say that, you
know, first I thought, oh my,
my one skill is actually product design
and product mention that I looked a
little bit deeper and I realized it was
probably something to do with empathy.
Yeah.
Do you think that's just the
key for consumer businesses?
Is it empathy kind of across the board?
Is that the thing to nail?
Not necessarily because I think,
you know,
with the help of amazing user researchers
who can tell you like these are your
three personas of, you know, the
three types of users that you're,
you're solving for. Like you can actually,
if you're an analytical, smart person,
if you have that data given to you,
rather than having to imagine it,
you can still be a
fantastic product designer.
I think the key with great consumer design
is product design is creating like a,
a kernel of, of delight, right?
Like it's not enough to have
a product that like does,
solves a problem and sort of
does what people ask you for.
You have to go way above and beyond and
there has to be this moment of like,
Whoa,
I didn't expect that.
Or that was amazing or unexpected to the
point where you would bother to tell a
friend, right? Like you're like, a
good example is actually snapchat.
When you take your, when you do the
filters and you do one that's uh,
the face swap,
right?
That's really clever because you didn't
expect that inside some sort of chat
app. And then it's inherently
viral. Like I'll, I'll,
I will sit there and show it to my friend,
like we'll do it together.
And that's a moment of
word of mouth delight.
So I think the secret to great
consumer products is you have to,
you have to grow, right? And you, you're
growing. If you're growing organically,
it's because people are talking about you.
And the way to get people to talk about
your product is to be, do something,
something above and beyond. That's
really, really delightful. So,
so that's how I think about it.
So what do you think the most important
thing was that you worked at while
you're at Polyvore?
And I'm wondering if you knew how
important it was at the time. Yeah,
I don't think I did. Um, but it
turned out to be culture. Uh,
in the beginning when you're starting,
you, the product you build as a, as a CEO,
as a founder, is the product, the
service that is delivered to your users.
But then as the company grows,
you know your attention actually you
get further and further away from the
product because you know, you're, you're
not the one writing the code anymore.
You're not the one making
the day to day decisions.
You're a managing through a team and the
product actually starts to become the
company and the organization.
And the same way that you instrument
your product and measure, you know,
is this feature working or not your
ab test or you carefully, you know,
you put Google analytics on everything.
You actually have to do the same thing
with your company and your team to make
sure it's healthy. Like are you measuring
your employee engagement scores?
Are People happy and thriving?
Like his code being checked in?
Like you actually have to pay a lot of
attention to how people work together.
And most importantly, the
culture is basically the
operating system. So it's, it's,
it's about building the
operating system for the company,
which is the culture.
And then all those,
those metrics and things that you monitor,
uh, and the larger, larger you'd get,
the more and more important it becomes
because you need people to be aligned on
how to behave.
And that's something I've always
thought was really great about Google.
I always felt like,
um,
there was a clear culture when I was here
and it was measured and defined and um,
really cared about and thrived and
everyone knew what the googly men,
and I think that's part of why
Google has always been successful.
So did you just for Google culture,
bring it over to
Polly?
No, actually I'd made them. There
are a lot of, is the same, right?
Like the empowering engineers
to make decisions, um,
and powering product people and trying
to try to be a little bit more bottoms up
or at least that's how it felt when
I was here. I copied a lot of that.
But the one thing I did not copy was the,
um,
and I think you can't at a startup is
you have to be very cognizant that you're
on a clock and you're running
out of money all the time.
Google has one of the best business
models in the world, right?
And is basically adwords and adsense are
printing money in the basement to power
all kinds of amazing project.
Now that's you know,
evolve to android or many
other business lines.
But that luxury of um,
oh we need to just purely focused on,
you know,
building the right product and not
have to worry too much about revenue,
which was the case.
It's probably changed since then.
But that was certainly
the case when I was here.
I could not copy that over to a startup
or you had 24 months of runway and it's
not even just the runway of money,
you're funding.
It's also the runway of people's
time and patients, right.
If you're underpaying your team and see,
cause you know,
they're not a Google or Facebook,
then you have to make sure they
see like a path to success.
So I think being much
more conscious about, uh,
spend as well as urgency
and people's time was,
was more,
it was a big part of our culture that
I would say it was different than the
Google. So a couple of
things I, I keep hearing is,
is learning people caring or these
are the things that motivated you,
has kind of your motivation been the
same across being an APM, being a CEO,
being at Yahoo,
being at sequoia,
uh, personal motivation. Um, I think I
care about two things. One is impact.
Like what kind of impact are you leaving,
what sort of debt are
you making the universe.
And the second is just personal growth and
learning, right? I found that if, again,
if you optimize for learning,
then you think about success and failure
in a different way because sometimes
you learn the most in the
toughest situations where
you are most likely to fail.
So if you reframe that conversation
into my learning or not learning and
learning is success,
then it kind of,
you stopped thinking about whether you
were getting the a or the sea or whether,
you know, you sold for, you know,
$1 billion or you know, 100 million.
Like you just, you just stop
thinking purely about the outcome,
which makes you afraid sometimes cause
you don't want to risk what you already
have. Um, and the other
is impact. Uh, you know,
one of the things that I really loved
about Polyvore was it was as it very
democratizing effect on fashion,
it was about letting a community of
women all around the world say, no,
this is what I think is stylish and I
don't want to listen to, I don't know,
the fashion magazines telling me this
is what you're supposed to look like.
And for the women who used it, it was
very empowering. And that allowed them to,
you know,
when you feel like you look a little
better than you might feel a little more
confident. And we had so many girls
from school age to call, you know,
girls applying to college,
told women just talking about
how it helped their confidence.
So for me that was always
part of the mission. Um,
and then part of the mission
for me at sequoia is, you know,
venture is probably 7% women,
uh,
and that I think has downstream impacts
on the percent of women who start
companies and uh,
the percent of innovation that happens
in fields targeted at women. Uh,
and then that affects exacts and you know,
all the way down the chain.
So I thought,
you know,
maybe if I could move into venture and
change the ratio just a little bit and
help backs, you know, amazing
founders, both men and women,
but I might be a little bit more
inclined to understand some of the female
founders who are working on products
targeted at women, which I was at 1.2.
So those are, that's
the, on the impact side.
How are you approaching your role
as a partner at sequoia? Now?
I know it's still relatively new,
but anything where you're like,
this is what I'm going to do.
I'm going to be focused on this,
I'm going to provide this value to
people. So I think my, you know, the,
the investors that do the
best are probably the ones
that are actually helpful
to their founders. So I've tried to focus
on like where can I be really helpful.
Um, and some of those areas are in
consumer, right? Because that's,
that was what I did that my whole
career has been mostly in consumer. Um,
I'm also starting to look at some spaces
like a ar and VR and robotics. Um,
I spent a lot of time meeting
female founders as well. Um,
I've been looking at
direct to consumer brands,
which is fairly new for venture and for
sequoia. Uh, yeah, those are, those are,
those are some of the areas that I tend
to focus on in any kind of niche fields
that you're kind of geeking out about,
excited about. I'm pretty excited about.
Um, robotics. I think now that computer,
you know, computer vision is of age,
computers can see,
uh,
you're seeing a lot more tech
moving out of like the phone.
Like instead of it being in a
little screen or on your desktop,
it's like moving out into the physical
world. Um, and maybe the first,
basically it's sort of the intersection
of, it's all the tech that,
that we know from the Internet and
moving from pure bits into the world of,
of atoms, right? So
maybe the earliest version of this
might be something like door dash or
instacart where a or Google
shopping express, right?
Where it's not just software
and you know, the, on my bugs,
okay, it's like software and then, oh my
God, all the problems of the real world,
like the driver was drunk or miss
the delivery or the food's cold.
Like these are not things that
software can catch. Right.
Which is why I think a lot
of these companies are run
by a hardcore operational
people who just know how to grind it out
and have a lot of grit because it's not
beautiful,
elegant software anymore.
And I think you're going to see more and
more of that as we move to fields like
robotics and more automation in the
real world. You realize that, you know,
you have to combine fashion and
robotics and I guess Google maps.
I have not seen that pitch yet, but that'd
be pretty cool. I'm sure we'll come up.
So before I ask you
about the most important
thing that you're working on at poly fort,
but what's the most important
thing that you're working on today,
if you're aware of it?
The most important thing,
um,
I think at the end of the day, like
Sequoia Sequoia's mission is to, you know,
help daring founders build
really legendary companies.
So the most important thing is to
find those people and help them. Um,
I've done two investments.
I spent a lot of time with those
founders and you know, one is a seed,
one is a series B because
I'm on the early stage team,
we do everything from a c to
two, basically series B, um,
is every day is just trying to
figure out how to help them. Um,
and then the other pieces,
you know,
I've been working on various initiatives
to try to figure out how to help female
founders more. So there'll be more
than that probably in a few weeks.
Okay. Yeah. I know you've been
doing a lot of talks lately, um,
conference couple weeks
ago for women in tech.
Yeah. Yeah. I love going to those events.
It's so amazing to see all the, um,
all the activity and the excitement.
So when you were running a startup, when
you're talking about product market fit,
how did you know when you nailed it?
I mean,
delight won't give you product market fit,
it'll give you vitality.
How do you know what you're actually
providing that value early on?
Um, so I actually do
think that when you found,
when you found delight and
you found product market fit,
that you do start to see organic growth.
Um,
you do start to see that that
word of mouth, you're right.
There are moments where you're
seeing that word of mouth for, uh,
other reasons.
Like maybe you had a really viral
piece of content on your platforms.
You have to be able to figure
out how to distinguish that.
But generally I think organic growth means
that you've found product market fit.
Um,
the question though is how large of a
market is it that you're working on and
how,
you know,
you can have product market fit for some
very tiny sliver of a market a or for a
particular user and you have to be able
to distinguish like is that enough?
Is this enough for a
sustainable company or not mean?
I think that's the biggest lesson that
I've learned on the venture side is you
know, I can assess the match
between maybe your user an product,
but thinking through the market structure
like is this a good market to be in?
Are there tons and tons
of competitors that are,
are the platform companies most likely
going to dominate the space in the long
run and therefore your
tech will be commoditized.
Thinking through those kinds of issues
and market size and market structure has
had sort of been one
of the biggest lessons.
Any tips for learning that stuff other
than joining a VC firm and thinking about
40 or 80 hours a week?
Yeah.
You know,
I think this is maybe something I didn't
do enough of as a PM is competitive
analysis, right? Like look through
what other people are like, you know,
you should always see, figure out
what's great about your product,
but you also have to think like,
when I say delight,
when you're going above and
beyond what people expect,
what people expect is set by what's
available in the market, right?
So just because you solve their problem
doesn't mean you're going to win if
there's another product that also
solves their problem but has much better
distribution than you do,
right?
So you really have to think about that
line of what people expect being set
partly by competitors,
right?
I'm a good example of this is when all
the smartphones came out right before
that, like blackberry was the best
phone, right? It had a keyboard,
you could do your email, and then when the
iPhone came out, I mean, that was just,
I don't need a keyboard. Like, I
can browse the entire web with us.
It just reset everyone's
expectations. And it took, you know,
a lot of companies died during that
because they didn't catch up and they were
just focused on what they were doing.
Right.
That you have to think about who
else is innovating out there,
what are they doing?
So I would say spending a lot of time
on competitive analysis and then also
thinking through, here's where we are
now, where will we be in five years?
Where will my competitors
be in five years? And then
skate towards that, you know,
skate to where the puck is going,
not to where it is right now.
So just getting really good at
thinking about that, um, is, is, uh,
is I think the most important thing
and I'm guessing that advice holds
true for CEOs for basically everybody.
Yes. I think that matters a lot for
founders and CEOs as well. Yeah.
The stage matter.
They're like,
shit early stage startup founders be
worrying about their competitors or should
they just be focused on delight
and value like you said.
Um,
I think you still have to think about it.
It's nothing that you spend
like everyday obsessing about.
Like I don't think you can be constantly
looking behind you in the, you know,
looking in the rear mirror,
but you have to know what the baseline
is and you have to have a sense and
that's part of it,
part of how you set your strategy and
then you just focus on getting to that
point. But you have to make sure you
do those checks periodically. You know,
maybe it could be once a
year if you're smaller,
it could be every quarter of your larger,
but it is really
important to have that to,
to check the expectations of the
market, uh, on a regular basis.
But focus most of your
time on actual execution.
Really curious what you think about, um,
you know, the early stages of community.
Obviously Polyvore had a
really good community. Um, I
had a good company culture.
Um,
do you see differences between how you
seed culture internally a company and how
you see that in a product?
Hmm. You know, I think it,
I think it's best if they're
somewhat aligned because if they are,
then I think it comes across
more authentically. Um,
for the community.
What we did is we,
the same way that we cared
about our individual employees,
we cared about our community.
When we would have a community event,
we would apply to do a few things well
rather than having a massive conference
where we couldn't really spend time
with people and we'd also just have the
money for that. We chose to
have smaller meetups, right?
So we sent like got 20 people that
come to New York fashion week with us.
Then we through a beautiful
breakfast for them,
we took a couple of them to some shows.
You tried to give them the
tickets instead of us going, um,
we owe our community manager and went
through all their Polyvore profiles and
picked out items at products that they
had used regular like regularly and then
bought them. We got our
advertisers to just give us swag,
like free stuff and coupons
and shoes or whatever.
We pack them into these bags and the,
I remember we had these breakfasts and
like some of these women would open it
and just start crying because they were
so happy and it was just the immense
delight was amazing and it was just
such a bonding moment for those teams.
And then they went on to talk, you know,
to the other committee members about it.
So it was great for us.
You know,
it's hard to measure whether that was
really like an Roi positive investment.
We just sometimes how
people think about can you,
but I think that's just not the
right way to think about it.
Like think about Zappos,
right?
Zappos has an amazing reputation
and that's because of,
you know,
good customer service,
but also like those stories of like the
woman who wrote in or was on a call with
a Zappos person for an hour
talking about how, you know,
she had like a whole series of life
events and therefore needed to return the
shoes and they'd let her return it and
then they cut counsel her for like an
hour and then gave her something for,
I don't know,
I don't even remember the Lord anymore,
but that's the point.
All I remember is there was a story and
it was amazing and that's part of what
cemented, I think the,
uh, the brand for Zappos.
Do you think people are focusing founders
as much as they should on culture
today?
Do you see a lot of these
really big scalable networks
that don't really have an
identity to them?
Yeah. Um, I think,
I think some,
sometimes it's easy to just be obsessed
with winning and not think about
culture.
And that's fine if you're always winning.
Like people love to work at companies that
are winning. That's a huge part of it.
I can't just have an amazing
culture and then like, you know,
driver company into the ground,
you have to have both.
But I think some companies have prioritize
the winning over over that treating
people well and that works as long
as you're on that upward trajectory.
But as soon as the going gets tough,
um,
I think people start to look around
and question and they're like,
why am I like the, I mean treated
horribly and then they start to, to bail.
So part of culture and creating that
right operating system is it smooths out
the bumps in the road,
right? Because you, you,
when the going gets tough, which it
almost always does at a startup, right?
There's always going to be
something that goes wrong. Um,
you get to keep your team together for
just a little bit long and they have a
little bit more loyalty,
a little bit more patience.
And that extends that runway that I was
talking about because it's not just a
runway of money and not
being able to pay people.
It's a runway is a runway of people's
patients, right? Like, as an employee,
you have a million things to choose, uh,
as a job, right? Like, if you're great,
you can,
you can come work at Google,
you can come work at Facebook
and then you get paid more or to,
but they choose to work at your startup
and you have to figure out like,
how do you,
how do you get that little bit of extra
loyalty when the going gets tough?
So I think culture is very,
very important.
And I think in general a silicon
valley does focused on culture. Um,
and every kind of culture there's,
you know,
they're co essentially the culture is, it
can be extreme. That's fine. Right? Um,
you know, yeah. But I think you treating,
treating employees right, it's really,
really important.
Yeah.
So if you weren't in Tuck your,
I'll say your daughter Sequoia,
let's say you're banned from
the tech industry forever.
Are you gonna go become a comic
book artist? Like what would you do?
That's a good question.
Uh,
I don't think I would make
it as a comic book artist.
I don't think I'm talented enough, but
I might give it a try anyway. Yeah.
Or professional costs
player. Oh really? Yeah.
Can we touch on that? Because
that's, that's divergent. Ah,
yeah.
Well I,
I I love anime and I cos
play now like rarely.
But yeah, that was pretty fun. Yeah.
So you were at Yahoo for a bit of time.
You were at Polyvore for a very long time.
You were at Google for a bit of time.
Um, those are three companies
and relatively similar spaces,
at least parts of them.
Okay.
What was it like working
across them over time?
Did you have to adapt yourself
to provide the most value,
provide the most impact? Or was it more
of this is what you bring to the table,
here's how you can influence
through group around you?
Oh, it changed a lot. Um,
so Google, I was, you know,
an APM fresh out of Stanford computer
science. I had never led a team before.
I had no idea what I was doing.
I never had a real job.
And you come into that situation with
a bunch of experienced engineers and,
and you're like, how do I get these
people to listen to me at all?
Like I have no credibility. Um, so
there, you know, I remember I was like,
how do I get them to respect me?
I know I'll fix a bug.
So I just checked in code and the,
and tried to prove that I was useful
and that was willing to work hard and
slowly built that
relationship with that team.
But it was all about rolling up your
sleeves and like getting stuff done. Um,
when that,
then when I had the credibility,
I was able to lay out more of like the
product roadmap, but everything was very,
very in the weeds and you know,
uh, working, working with the team,
making decisions myself.
Um, at Polyvore it was, uh,
early days, very similar,
right? Like, I mean, I,
they hired me and I didn't have to work
so hard to earn the respect, but um,
it was a lot of in the weeds
of making decisions, writing
code, all of that stuff.
Then when you switched to becoming a
manager or VP or getting moving up in the
org,
you're no longer focused on the solution.
You are focused on the
problem. Right, and the art.
I think the reason why no one likes Mike,
like no one really likes micromanager
and what's annoying is that the micro
manager is a person who's trying to tell
you, here's how you, here's the solution.
Let me tell you like do it this way,
do it my way.
And what you really want is an of like,
no,
this is the problem we're trying to solve.
The reason I don't like your solution
is because you didn't think about this
part of the problem.
So if you just articulate the problem
clearly and the guard rails of like,
you know what's acceptable and not,
then people start to come up with the
solutions that are a little bit closer to
what maybe you think is ideal and inner.
They don't.
You have to sell except it sometimes,
but because it could be totally right.
I've been proven wrong
many, many times, right?
As I'm sure we all have if we're managers,
but that just keeps changing
as you grow in the org.
So you start with a solution creator,
then you become a problem creator.
And then at some point no
one tells you anything.
There's no problem given to you
and you don't have to articulate,
you're just here you are a VP at Yahoo,
create value for our company and then
no one tells you, you know, so we had,
we invented products.
Right. So that's, that's,
that's a very different
way of thinking. Um, but I,
I would say that that was the difference
between all the different roles in
stages.
So did you approach that by trying to
find problems for people or did you just
try to find a teams and then say,
bring me problems are important. Yeah,
so I sat up very, we, you know, I was,
I was the VP of the lifestyle group and
we know, we knew that to create value,
we wanted to build a bigger mobile user
base for Yahoo Cause it was still quite
a homepage, desktop centric. Um, I
actually had a lot of young, younger,
whether it's amazing,
but still more mobile growth.
And we wanted lifestyle, which
to me meant, you know, younger,
a younger audience,
um, and a lot of women.
So then what we did is we
started outlining like what
are the verticals that we
could go into health and wellness,
fashion,
beauty, uh, social. And so
we picked verticals. And,
uh, then what we did is we started
to build out user personas.
What are the different types
of people in this space?
And then what are the problems? And
uh, what I did was I didn't tell them,
here are the people I know exactly
like what, you know, women 18,
13 to 25 wine. I said, here are the
breadwinners of those users. Um,
come up with a process to
understand these people.
And then the team got really good at that.
They got great at creating user personas.
They became amazing at running,
coming up with, uh, a brainstorm.
Um, Eric go is, it was involved in,
it's actually your why she's,
she's awesome.
And they would run a process with the
team to brainstorm different products.
And then we came up with a process
for how to test that very quickly.
And then what we ended up doing is
creating a process to get apps shipped in
eight weeks.
So we would brainstorm and then eight
weeks later we would push something to
android and it would be an MVP,
but we'd get enough data.
And then we do two or
three more iterations.
And there we actually shipped I think
four or five apps inside of Yahoo under
some, you know, umbrella companies.
I didn't say Yahoo on it because
we didn't want to risk the brand,
but it was like a great fun thing
for the team to work on. Um,
for various reasons. Well, we
didn't ship all of them, you know,
some of them actually sucked. Uh, and
some them had interesting traction,
but we ended up deciding that
they weren't strategic. Uh,
and the one that eventually
launched was Cabana by Tumblr,
which is a live streaming, a
group watching APP. Um, you know,
I think there's a lot more work
to be done, but you know, I,
I think that that's sort of how we manage
that process or how I manage it as,
as the, the VP without, while
wanting to empower the team,
but also making sure we were doing
something useful in strategic for Yahoo.
It's really interesting. Yeah. And
these were teams of five people,
so three I think three
or four, no, six, three,
three or four engineers and then a
designer and a pm. So very small team.
Eight weeks.
Yeah.
So we do have, um, a dory
with some questions and we
also have a mic in the back.
So the dory link for anyone on the live
stream is go slash ask Dash Jess Lee.
Um, but why don't we bring this
up and take a few of these? Okay.
So what's the difference between being
a PM at Google and being a CEO at a
startup and in your case,
did you see any challenges during that
transition and how did you get over them?
Yeah. Um, so I think I've
mentioned some of that. The,
the culture and the environment in terms
of like having to think through revenue
very early on was it was
different. Um, you know,
at Google the,
the responsibility was much more
about the product and less about the,
the people in the org or the product
became, um, the company at, at,
at the CEO stage. Um, it,
it was a challenging
transition. Like I said, I,
I've constantly felt like I didn't really
know what I was doing and I just kept
the job,
just kept evolving underneath me and
then I figured it out and then it would
change again. So, yeah. Okay.
So you've been on both the building
and financing side of products and
businesses,
so which would you pick?
Oh, that's a tough question. Um,
there are pros and cons to each
write on the building side.
As a founder and a CEO, um,
that's, there's a lot of, uh,
existential stress,
right? Because you become,
your identity becomes the company
you're constantly worried about.
Are we going to make it,
you know,
I've brought 125 people with me on
this journey. Like what am I, you know,
is this going to work out for all of us?
So it's much more existentially stressful
than being on the investors side where
your,
um,
the value of your work is spread out
across a portfolio of companies versus all
your risk tied to one single company
that you are responsible for.
So existential stress is much
higher on the founder side. Um,
I do miss getting my hands dirty,
right? Like writing code, you know,
making product design,
they get to do a little bit of it with
my earlier stage companies so that,
so that scratches that itch.
Um,
I would say though that the learning is
enormous and that's a huge upside. Um,
by being an investor.
Like too,
it's such a privilege to meet so many
amazing founders working on so many
different markets. Like everyday I
learn something about the latest,
greatest state of some technology or
a market that I wouldn't have known
anything about. Uh, and it's
just a privilege to meet
all those awesome people.
And to just constantly be learning.
Okay.
So a lot of times people,
I mean you always hear,
don't identify too much with your work,
but you see people do it all the time.
Do you think that's actually a useful
thing for startup founders to be doing?
You said as a startup founder,
you sometimes see people's opinions of
the startup being a reflection of your
work. Is that a good thing to care
that much? Like to be that invested?
You know, I think that there's, uh,
there's certainly a personal
sacrifice that comes with it,
but part of me also feels like it's
necessary in order to get through it.
So yeah, I think it's, it's
a, it's a little inevitable.
Like if you're too checked out,
you don't really care what happens
with your company. Like, yeah, I don't,
I think it's hard to actually tough
it out and, and, and make it work at,
and I feel like I've been making startups
not really terrible. It just not right.
It's, it's just that it's epic
highs and epic Lowe's. Right.
And the epic has made it all worth it.
Like,
I had so many moments where I was like,
I can't believe this is my job.
I found my calling in life.
This is amazing. I love my team.
Like this is the best feeling in the
world. And then also moments of like,
oh my God, why did I leave Google? Right.
But that's just par for the course.
And I think it's like that for, for
every, every founder and every CEO. Yeah.
That's why we take a live
question in the back.
Thank you. Thanks so much for coming to
Google. It's really interesting talk. Um,
I have a question.
Did you come across in sequoia?
Any interesting fashion
tech companies? Yeah. Um,
I have seen a lot.
The problem is I know where all the dead
bodies are buried because I did fashion
tech.
So they actually say that to a lot of
times investors are less likely to invest
in things that they've kind
of, they know too well. Uh,
so I feel a little bit like
that. Um, something, let's
see. What would have I seen?
I think there's a lot of interesting
computer vision stuff that's happening now
that enables fashion,
fashion companies.
Fashion is one of the hardest,
uh,
recommendation problems,
right? Like, you know,
Netflix had the whole Netflix prize
for figuring out movie recommendations.
But do you think about it,
there's not that many movies,
like how many movies come out per year,
not that many.
And then how much does your movie
tastes change versus fashion?
It's like not only does your tastes
change over the years, like trends change,
seasons change,
and then you know,
the amount of product out there is
astonishing and it's very difficult to
describe, right? Like little touches
like silk or white stripe here.
Like it's just so unstructured.
It's very difficult and people like
very specific things. And so it's,
it's one of the most difficult
problems. Um, so one of, you know,
there's some really interesting computer
vision companies that are, you know,
classifying products that look similar.
And I think that that's
a very interesting space.
I think he'd do a lot more once
you have vision. Yeah. Okay.
Another question in the back. He's
just, thanks so much for coming here.
I'm going to shun the
BM and search. Hi. Uh,
one of the things I'm curious to know
a little bit more about is how did you
having a focus versus writing a blog,
being the marketing person,
being the salesperson,
being the product manager
and so on and so forth.
Can you touch a little bit more on that?
Yeah,
so what I tried to do was I always had
my core duties of product management and
then I tried to only do one new
frontier thing outside of that.
So I was not writing code and doing ad
sales and the blog at the same time.
I did the blog first and I was like,
oh,
there's a lot of community stuff to do
here. Let me hire a community manager.
And then she took over that. Then I, um,
I think after that I moved to add sales.
Uh,
I did a little bit and hired a great
New York Times salesperson. Um,
and so they were more one,
you know,
it's one extra thing.
Yeah.
How many people were at
Polyvore when you joined?
Uh, just the founders. So
three. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
And when you left 125, a
little bit bigger. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Another question, the back
adjust. Uh, so, um,
do the things that you talked about
being very important to you were having a
big impact and a kind of doing a
lot of learning, like cross cross,
cross disciplinary areas.
Um,
it Kinda seems like at a company like
Google scale, it can be hard to, uh, um,
have as big of an impact on the thing
that you're working on and also to kind of
be given those additional responsibilities
or even like to be able to seek them
out yourself. Did you have
any like, advice for a,
I guess trying to find
those opportunities, um,
when you're in like a bigger company?
Yeah. Yeah, that's it. It can
be harder. Um, for sure. Uh,
what I would recommend and what I
think I ended up doing actually inside
Polyvore as well. It was
just go do them, you know,
like if you see something like come up
with the solution or do a little bit of
that work and then bring it to the person
who maybe owns that area by being mad,
you'd be like, Hey, you know, could I
work? Look, I already did some work here.
Can I prove to them that they should
have you helping before you ask them,
can I help you? Right. Like,
just go ahead and do it. Uh, so,
so that was a big part of, of my drain,
I think, um, that works anywhere.
Um, in terms of impact, I, yeah, I mean,
Google touches so many,
many,
many people though that even when
you own a small part of something,
you might still be as impactful as working
on a huge thing inside of a company
with much less many fewer
users. Um, yeah. But, you know,
I think autonomy is maybe one of the key
differences between small startup and
at large company.
So that one's very hard to,
I think you just have to pick
where you want to be. Yeah. Thanks.
So another question from the dory,
it's part of being a CEO and
a pm is making hard decisions.
Can you share an example of one
of these really hard decisions?
How you approached it?
Yeah. Um, so let's see.
We pivoted our business model twice.
Um, and then, uh, that's probably,
those are hard decisions.
Uh,
and then other hard
decisions were probably, uh,
when people had to leave.
Right.
I would say one thing that's
interesting about startups,
I didn't realize until I went through it,
is there are people who are just
awesome at the early stage, right?
They love being one of 10 people.
They're so good,
they're jacks of all trades and they
just love the freedom and the autonomy.
And then as the company
gets bigger, you know, they,
they start to feel really like encumbered
and they don't like it anymore. And
You keep trying to make it work
because you just like love that person.
But really the best thing
to do is actually let them
go free and find the next
company. So those were some of the
hardest decisions because I was like,
why isn't it working?
Let's just make it work.
We'll just like rearrange the universe to
work and it just doesn't work that way.
Some people are just great for different
stages, so I think that was a hard one.
Um, the other one was like
I mentioned just pivoting,
sometimes there there's
pull, they're like, you know,
your business model is not working and
you're not making money and you have to
do something else. So those are
difficult to roll out to a team. Right?
Like if a whole group of people work on
this particular business model and our
low longer needed, right. Like
that's very difficult. But you,
you have to do the right thing for the
company and for the greater good of that,
of that group.
Yeah.
Now that you are evaluating new
companies and potential investments and
potential founders that you're looking at,
do you consider that
when looking at founders,
like is this person a great
in the beginning but I worry
about them the long run
or is it too hard to protect?
It's pretty hard to predict.
Like honestly,
I think if you met me like before
Polyvore you might not have assume that I
would have been able to get
to the larger company stage.
I'm on more on the introverted side.
I hate public speaking. Like it's,
uh, I don't, you know, I,
I don't think you would've said that
person can definitely scale to run like,
you know, have vps and stuff reporting
into them. Uh, so I, I try to be very,
very open minded about that and
they just look for that grit, right?
Like it distance traveled. Like,
can you keep pushing yourself?
You have a history of pushing herself
because he might be able to push yourself
all the way through because it's not,
it's not rocket science, right? It's hard,
but it's, it's a lot of trial and
error and just learning on the job.
So is that, that's more
what I look for. Yeah.
Any advice for introverted
PM's are founders? Yes.
Yeah. I mean, I think you can be a
great leader even if you're very,
very introverted, right? Um, you know,
you might not be the highlight
of a cocktail party or something,
but that who cares, right?
At the end of the day,
you have to be able to convince your team
of what the vision is. You have to, uh,
be able to rally them. Um,
you know, for my all hands,
I really hated speaking in front
of the whole company a lot.
So what I did is I actually had,
um,
a lot of the other folks on the team
speak and explain what they were doing.
Right. Which is actually nice
because people like be, you know,
other people like being in the spot.
They like getting credit
for what they're doing.
Instead of me talking the entire
time that, that was, uh, uh,
that was something that I
did. And, and, w you know,
I was still able to have
lots of really meaningful,
great one on one conversations
or small group conversations.
And because I didn't like public speaking,
I would always have slides. Right.
I'm a, I love to draw. I'm a designer,
so I would make sure that
whenever I was giving a talk,
I had a beautiful set of slides so
that everyone would be looking at that
instead of it. Um, and that helped me.
He made me less nervous. And it also,
I think with a guide for what I
needed to say. And um, yeah, you know,
you just find your, your
tips and your tricks. Um,
I think he'd be a great leader
as an introvert or an extrovert.
Yeah. Can we take out the other
questions from the back? Okay. Um, okay.
I was wondering if you could share your
most recent public investment and I
guess like what drove you to
actually invest in that team?
Yeah,
so it's installed
so I can't share it.
Um,
maybe I can tell you a little bit about
what they do. Um, so this company is an,
uh, an item demand staffing
up platform. So they match,
uh, workers, blue collar
workers to jobs, uh,
or shifts at companies like
target or Uniclo or you know,
at a warehouse. Um, they're live
in like eight different cities,
so it's not just a San Francisco problem,
but you know,
there's a lot of people who,
I mean,
there's a lot of unemployment
in this country. Um,
and some of it is actually
due to inefficiencies.
So they are a marketplace that matches
people. Um, really great hardworking,
humble team.
They continue to do jobs on the weekends
themselves just to make sure they don't
forget what it's like.
Uh,
and a lot of distance traveled with these
founders. So I really love their, uh,
their grit.
Yeah. Well, I guess
kind of a follow up, um,
do you think that there's a trend of,
I guess like a lot of startups that focus
more on middle America and like a lot
more blue collar things, um,
that tend to succeed? Um,
and might be harder to find as an investor
since like investors tend to be in
like the Silicon Valley bubble or
like New York, stuff like that.
Yes. I do think that that's true. Um, I,
it's something I think about
a lot. Like I think, you know,
is this thing gap widening,
uh, like, or you know,
does it help with obviously I,
you know,
we're not pure impact social investors
like sequoia is where it is and has been
for 45 years because it
produces tremendous returns
consistently and his back
legendary companies like
Google or apple or Nvidia,
uh, and airbnb. Uh, and it is so,
it is important that it, it does drive
performance and drive returns, but I do.
Those are, those are things that I think
about and I think those are a lot of,
there are a lot of untapped opportunities
and I think that the company had just
mentioned falls perfectly in that realm.
Yeah.
So why don't we take it
one more Tory question.
It's what is something that Google can
learn from other companies now that
you're back here after like a decade,
what lessons you brought back for us?
Huh, wow. I mean it's hard
to tell Google like, hey,
you're not doing very well because
that's clearly not the case. Um,
I thought it was very clever to break up
Google into multiple companies to give
more autonomy and breathing room to,
and like leadership for a lot of people.
I thought that was a very,
very clever thing.
So I guess that's more something that
other companies can maybe learn from
Google. Um, and I, and again,
I think that comes from maybe caring
about you that growth and investing in
people or maybe there's financials.
I don't know, but, but that,
that's how I thought about it.
Let's see. I do think the, the
focus, the one thing that I
had already mentioned was, um,
just knowing that you have a runway
and that sense of urgency. Um,
I do think that sometimes that can be
really helpful, helpful, forcing function.
Like when you're in a meeting with someone
for the third meeting about the same
topic and you can't get everyone to agree
and you're trying to get consensus. Um,
sometimes it's good to think like we,
we have six months to live, right?
Like do we,
should we be arguing about this right now?
Cause I think getting rid of some
of those extra meetings would,
would make people a lot happier probably.
So maybe that's my one thing.
And then why don't we take one last
question from the back and then we'll wrap
up. Right. Thanks. Thanks Doug.
Thanks. Thanks for organizing it.
So first let me apologize by saying that
I know we're been to Polyvore side and
so, um, part of me, um,
so I understand that the users
were a big component of your,
your product design and success
of the company, uh, in sometimes,
but you just get to two powerful,
sometimes there are power users that
troll you and the entire user community in
the fall.
Sometimes there are power users get
their power users within the segment of
users, the troll, everything. Uh,
was this the case in [inaudible] case
there you've got blindsided by what users
were saying in some certain cases or
where you had to take a decisions against.
What do you use?
We ask asking for thoughts.
Yeah.
I think knowing your users and listening
to your users does not mean doing
everything your users.
Cause sometimes they ask for things
that just don't make sense. Right?
Like if every user was a
product, you know, designer,
then we'd all be, you know,
designing products and we all
be reach entrepreneurs. Um,
so you have to listen to, you know,
when they say I want something,
you have to think, okay,
you're giving me a solution.
What was the problem you
were trying to solve?
And then you have to remember that for
every vocal user there is a ton of silent
users out there, which is why for
us personas were very important.
So we had clear personas for
the different types of users.
There was a creator who made all the
content and was constantly asking us for
features and talking. And then there were
the more casual shoppers and browsers,
and we had personas for them as well.
Um,
so I think you use user research
plus talking to your users,
plus personas and all these other tools
to get a sense of how much to prioritize
across your entire user base. But yeah,
I definitely don't just listen directly,
do everything that is,
let's thank Jeff for coming.
It's been great for having me.